come on Diana what else he got so Wonder
Woman is a hit it is officially
undeniably a hit already knew it was a
critical hit audiences are really liking
it did over 100 million dollars in its
opening weekend which was ahead of the
initial estimates and it is a bigger
opening than any of the solo marvel
first outings bigger than Ironman bigger
than Doctor Strange bigger than the
first Thor did more than any of them
this is huge
so the question is what comes next and
the first thing I want to talk about
before I say about possibilities that
could happen it is depressing how clear
it has become that Warner Brothers had
almost no faith in this movie whatsoever
I really do get the feel that they made
this thing out of obligation not now
that it's a hint hopefully they'll do
something really good with it but there
were the early indicators like the fact
that Wonder Woman did not have as big a
budget as the DC movies had been granted
up to this point but it's become
painfully clear in the wake of this
thing being if they can't because
obviously we'd expect the sequel talk to
be coming out and there's not much and
what there is seems to be if not
contradictory at least scattered patty
Jenkins has said a number of things a
number of different places she is
indicated that they haven't even started
working on story yet she's indicated
that she'd like it set in the u.s. she's
indicated that it could be set in any
number of different time periods it's
very clear that no preliminary work was
done on a sequel ahead of the release of
the movie that is crazy because in the
time that we live in with the way these
franchises work and the way that they
are built and how early the work gets
done even if they're not going to pull
the trigger on like a ton of
pre-production you think at least they
would have story laid out if nothing
else but no not even that no script
commissioned no nothing nothing has been
done towards a second Wonder Woman they
couldn't even throw in a
and after credit sequence just a hint at
some vague posit nip zero Warner
Brothers I'm not going to say they
expected this to fail but they certainly
were not prepared to commit any
resources time or money towards the
expectation of there being a sequel now
Warner Brothers didn't you know sabotage
this and obviously didn't want it to
fail but it being is very clear at this
point they were not banking on it
succeeding so moving on from that the
question becomes now what actually do we
do with the sequel because I mean which
we're going to get one there's no way
that they can justify not giving her a
proper sequel and there are frankly a
lot of possibilities there is a whole
swath of time between when this movie
came out and when BBS came up that you
can have her app any kind of adventure
set in there now I know some people are
going to go all but she said she
abandoned Mann's world and all this so
we obviously had the implication in BBS
that between whatever her origin film
was that which we've now gotten to see
and BBS that she was inactive now they
can claim that all they want but you
know what that is a big wide canvas for
them to play with and I think it's in
their interest to worry less about
contradicting that than just taking
advantage of what there is so they can
set a follow-up to Wonder Woman in any
time period between World War One and
Batman V Superman or they can even go
past that and go after it sounds like
patty Jenkins is more interested in
moving along the timeline as opposed to
jumping right to modern day and there's
certainly a lot to be done there there
is potentially setting our up for world
war two which is the point at which the
character was actually introduced the
reality because that is the war that she
participates in much like when Captain
America was introduced now I doubt
they're going to do that just because I
don't think we need another war movie
with her in it but in my sight they
really kind of did they did that really
well and I can't think of what you would
do with a world war ii set Wonderwoman
story that wasn't
have already tackled in some way in this
first film I just think it would be
we're done that it would smack of trying
to recreate to the letter what you did
last time as opposed to progressing
things forward so I don't think that's
on anybody's plan and I it better not be
now I'm personally slightly disappointed
at Teddy Jenkins suggestion that she
wants to set it in the US because for me
personally what I would really like to
see more of is more of the mascara and
more of the mythological end of things
because it was very important to
introduce Diana to man's world show her
interactions with it so how she came to
connect with it but honestly my own
interest now that we've gotten that
story is going to be much more in the
mythological end of things for a couple
of reasons the first is honestly you can
get more outlandish and a little bit
more creative with that I would kind of
like to see it go there and one of the
other things is unfortunately one of
Wonder Woman's weaknesses as a character
in terms of her own comic book series is
that she doesn't have a particularly
good rogues gallery and in a way it
actually because of one of her strengths
and one of the things that makes her
unique throughout her history she has
had a tendency to actually convert her
foes into heroes that I should do one of
the things that's been really great
about her she wants the passive piece
first and as a result of that she's
actually converted quite a few of her
villains into heroes or at least some
form of antihero someone who is in a
flat-out villain anymore but that does
mean that her actual stable of recurring
villains is both kind of small and a
little bit weird and wonky and not
particularly great cheetah is kind of
like the big one that people know but
it's hard to choose the kind of
character who's hard to build a movie
around because she's largely just a
physical threat to Diana and combat so
it would be like trying to build a
Batman movie around Killer Croc and
nobody else and it doesn't really quite
work so one of the things that is what
was one of the smarter things that the
new 52 Wonder Woman did when it started
before then with George Perez rebooting
in the 80s but sort of those
reinventions in those eras was bring in
more of the mythological aspects now
we've gotten some of that already with
Ares but I mean you can go
out with this you can address things
like Hercules or you can have creatures
uh like the Medusa the Minotaur the
Hydra stuff like that and I think doing
that and also honestly getting us back
on South hemisphere again and again yes
I understand that in the movie it was
implied through a line from a policy
that Diana could not go back but
honestly that's been said in the comics
too and they find ways to get her back
to bring her back whether the Amazons
summon her whether something desperate
happens is she really need that whatever
you can work around that
that's time not taking that as written
in stone either but I think some sort of
direct threat to sent us here oh that is
more mythological in nature would be a
nice way to kind of scale things up
because I would like to think that since
this what movie has been such a big hit
uh Warner Brothers would be willing to
put some more money behind the follow-up
because as much as I did enjoy Wonder
Woman and actually I've seen it a second
time now and I like just more the second
time that I liked it the first time even
but I would like to see if I'll have
more money put behind it because the
effects are not the best I I cited the
green screen before but even besides
from that and some of the sort of
digital body doubles you know it reads
it's a little bit Matrix Reloaded at
times but again it's not if they're not
atrocious effects but they're not quite
up to par from what we usually expect
especially from DC who has thrown a lot
of money at the other movies and their
franchises up to this point so if
they're willing to spend a bit more
money we could really get some very cool
stuff and I would like to see that now
the one thing I would say about that is
even though I want to see that at some
point that doesn't have to be the
immediate follow-up sequel because she
can go back to that mascara at any time
that doesn't need a period setting you
could do that as her quote-unquote
modern day setting so it's not necessary
to actually have that be the immediate
follow-up if pedagogues wants to play
with her in time periods a little bit
more exactly where you go that I I don't
know off the top of my head because I'm
not
Whitehead steeped in Wonderwoman history
and others one thing that I would
honestly suggest tackling I know people
who know Wonder Woman a little bit
better than me are going to cringe on
this but stick with me there was a
period in which she was depowered and
this was generally called the Wonder
Woman mod era and this is not well
regarded material at all but the thing
is it's not so much on the concept it's
on the execution so what happened was
and I met there there are much more
detailed things you can find out about
this a nerdsync did a video deep diving
into this a little bit more if you want
some more details short version is
Wonder Woman in her desire to stay with
Steve Trevor ended up losing her powers
now she still tried to be a hero and to
do good she got a little bit more into
sort of espionage martial arts type
stuff and there were some really wonky
ill-advised ideas in terms of the way
that they were characterizing her at the
time she was made much less the you know
the person who tries to pass a piece
first she was made much more hot-headed
she was made much more driven by her
emotions
they gave her a fashion and a shopping
obsession in with it was a good stuff
but honestly the idea of the D powered
Wonder Woman particularly if you're
going to do a period setting in that 60s
70s era I think could actually yield
some measure C stories and again
bringing Warner Brothers back into it if
they aren't willing to really up the
budget too much from what it has been
that would also be an opportune subway
to go obviously she's going to regain
her powers by the end yet to come up
with a different reason for her losing
her powers than she did it for the love
of Steve Trevor because obviously Steve
Trevor is now netting it Stan cover is
dead okay I've seen it I've seen it
mentioned a few people like oh we don't
know definitively cuz you know you be
some because the camera is not like
right in the airplane to watch the
flames watch over him some people are
going to try and claim that he can be
brought back I'm not going to say it's
impossible because you know comics are
stupid that way in terms of being able
to bring people back but it wasn't
really
good death it was he was a good
character their relationship was well
built and it was a good death don't
don't
bring that back leave him dead so he
would have to shift her motivation or
why she ends up losing her powers
because again in the comics she gave
them up maybe something else happens but
I think depowering her could yield some
interesting things and also you know for
when you get more to modern times with
her more the BBS era you know it might
give her a greater appreciation for what
it is she's capable of doing but again
the other just some ideas I may have for
things that they could do I'm actually
way more interested in whatever patty
Jenkins has up her sleeve on what she's
thinking because I think that this this
first Wonder Woman movie really
delivered there's some rough edges but
those are the sorts of things that can
be streamlined and can be sanded off and
can work better next time around
especially if they're one of my major
issues with the file not major issues
but one of the things that I was kind of
back and forth on was Diana how naive
she was and obviously she's kind of lost
that at the end of this movie so that
should be gone if they either streamline
the story so that it doesn't require the
special effects in the same level so
that we don't see that there was special
text iron dumps it's not or better
Warner Brothers is willing to spend the
money on better special effects that'll
fix that problem and then yeah honestly
that's most of my issues with the first
movie easily fixed for the sequel if
they can just nail a climax that isn't
quite so much just fury and noise and
boom that pretty much be my ideal Wonder
Woman whether it's set in modern day
whether it's set in the past whether
it's at a cemetery you you fix those
three things one which is is already
fixed because the naive aspect of her
character has been dealt with it they
can wipe their hands of that I just yeah
I will have nothing to complain on
bottom will have as far as I'm concerned
a woman movie so those are my general
thoughts about where the follow-up to
Wonder Woman could should or maybe
shouldn't go from here what are your
thoughts on the future of Wonder Woman
add a singular hero obviously she's
going to have her
moment in justice league shall probably
make appearances in other movies I'm
talking about our solo series what do
you think can should or shouldn't happen
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geese give listeners the
Council of geeks podcast home of a new
feature that I am calling go home
Hollywood you're drunk
give that a check you can also listen to
the punch like a girl podcast that is a
separate podcast feed so thank you so
much for tuning in and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]